lawsuits the reason the sentence Greta
thong burg allegedly killed Jeffrey
Epstein has the word allegedly in it
look we'll get to the main substance of
our story in a little bit but before we
do I actually need to give you a quick
update on something you may remember
that in 2017 we add a piece on the coal
industry that touched on this man Bob
Murray the then CEO of Murray energy the
largest privately held coal company in
America in our piece we discussed his
closeness to the President Trump his
company's lawsuits to block a rule
intended to limit - exposure to coal
dust and his insistence that a deadly
2007 mine collapse was the result of a
naturally occurring earthquake something
decidedly at odds with a government
investigation which found that it was
caused by unauthorized mining practices
now before the show went out Murray's
attorneys had sent us two separate
letters warning us that if we aired the
story he would sue and threatening that
home box office is in for the fight of
its existence which that might actually
be true but not because of his lawsuit
it's because Game of Thrones prequels
including Game of Thrones the college's
Game of Thrones Winterfell Valley High
and throne babies battle for the rattle
won't be out for at least a year
HBO's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
but you may know we went ahead with the
story anyway and this happened comedian
John Oliver is the target of a lawsuit
by one of the country's largest
privately owned coal companies Oliver
strongly criticized Murray Energy
Corporation and CEO Robert Murray Sunday
and his HBO show last night we last week
tonight it's true Bob Murray sued us
after that episode of last night week
last week tonight's edge although and
this is true that's not the title of our
show and frankly I expect better from an
esteemed program like CBS morning night
this morning hey you up our name we
up yours that was over two years
ago and ever since because the case has
been in litigation we haven't been able
to discuss it but recently Murray
actually dropped the lawsuit so I have
some good news I can finally tell you
exactly what happened which is honestly
worth doing not only because it's a
crazy story but because it actually
points to a much bigger problem here but
first a
background on the lawsuit itself in it
Murray listed what he found
objectionable in our piece including
that we described him as someone who
looks like a geriatric dr. evil which we
did and he does and also that we
arranged for a staff member to dress up
in a squirrel costume and deliver the
message
each ship Bob and actually don't don't
even remember that happening can we just
quickly can we just a moment check the
tape it's me now to you each it bad fair
enough my mistake we did it it's funny
the things you forget that each it check
was actually a reference to a real thing
that one of Murray's minors wrote on a
bonus check that he received that the
background to that story was that Murray
had implemented a bonus program to his
miners based on the amount of coal they
extracted his workers union objected to
that believed he would have an adverse
impact on safety in the mines and when
Murray did it anyway
the miner returned his bonus check off
by the way $3.22 with the words each
Bob written on it and the company
tried to fire him for that which seems
pretty excessive maybe that message was
just an invitation to eat at Bob
the airport Express version of Bob Evans
need need a slick biscuit and some sake
sausage slop before your flight then you
have gotta come on down
[Music]
we've all heard the jingle anyway
Murray's lawsuit against us asked for
damages because he claimed that nothing
has ever stressed him more than our
quote vicious and untruthful attack
which is odd thing to say given that as
I just mentioned he oversaw a company
whose mine collapse in Utah resulted in
the deaths of nine people it went on to
say that we attacked Murray in a forum
in which he had no opportunity to defend
himself which is just not how anything
works and besides after launching his
lawsuit Murray did defend himself and
very publicly will pursue it to the
fullest this is a tragedy and American
businessmen had better take note as to
what they are trying to do with me
a guy who's done nothing in his life but
follow the law create jobs and do
everything I could as best I could for
our country these people are evil
they're very evil hey hey well I think
evil is a bit much there look you can
say a lot of things about me for
instance that I look like a toucan who
can't sleep without a nightlight or but
my voice sounds like Jude Law if you had
a kazoo stuck in his throats but evil
seems like a bit of an exaggeration now
obviously the lawsuit was a
effort to silence us perhaps best
exemplified by a motion that Murray
filed to try and get a gag order to
prevent us from rebroadcasting the story
or even having it up online and for the
record the piece is still on the
Internet's big time and you can actually
find it at still on the Internet big
time calm so beautiful short cut so it
was no surprise when the case was
dismissed by the West Virginia judge who
heard it last February and at that point
we figured this whole saga was over
right well wrong because Murray then
filed an appeal to the West Virginia
Supreme Court and here's a fun side note
one of the judges set to hear our case
was Justice Allen Laurie and that name
weirdly ranks something of a bell for us
and then we remembered that in 2015 we
actually does did a segment on elected
judges
that commented on one of his campaign
ads here is a clip from that show hi I'm
Alan Laurie
for our Supreme Court it's la pre is in
law and free this is my house come on in
there's the kitchen something smells
good in my family room my wife Kelly law
free in our son justice law free that's
right justice Lockwood yeah I called my
son justice I called my dog preamble and
I call my penis the gavel bow for me
oopsie I mean as far as things to say
about a judge before he makes a ruling
on your case goes claiming that he calls
his penis the gavel is maybe not the
best choice even though look at him he
clearly does so so we were naturally
pretty concerned at this point but then
in a bizarre twist all four justices of
the state Supreme Court including
justice Lorie were impeached in a
scandal over inappropriate spending so
our case wound up just sitting there for
over a year until a few months ago when
out of nowhere
Murray's team offered to drop their
lawsuit impossibly related news Murray
energy recently announced it will be
reorganizing under bankruptcy though you
should know Bob Murray will remain the
company's chairman but we did wonder
what was the point of him putting us
through all of this in the first place
well I would argue it's because winning
the case was never really his goal and
that brings us to the larger issue that
we're going to talk about tonight slap
soos slap is an acronym that stands for
strategic lawsuit against public
participation these are frivolous suits
with no legal merits specifically
designed to stifle public debate or
dissent and these happen all the time
and Murray is not alone in seemingly
using lawsuits to punish and intimidate
his critics in fact one of his good
friends has openly called for changes
that would make it easier to file them
I'm gonna open up our libel laws so when
they write purposely negative and
horrible and false articles we can sue
them and win lots of money so we're
gonna open up those libel laws folks and
we're gonna have people sue you like you
never got sued before
it's through Trump has been as
enthusiastic about opening up libel laws
as he's been unenthusiastic about
opening up a birthday present from
Tiffany look I know it's a tie you know
it's a tie the only thing that isn't a
tie is how much I love my daughter's
trunk
chuck is famously liturgist and has
launched a number of what I would argue
are slap suits for instance when
journalist Tim O'Brien reported in a
book that sources close to Trump claimed
his net worth was much lower than he
claimed and only somewhere between 150
to 250 million Trump did not take that
well when the book came out he didn't
feel very good about it he ultimately
sued me for defamation I think it's the
biggest libel lawsuit in US history he
sued me for five billion dollars it's
true
Trump sued that man for five billion
dollars and think about that that means
if Trump had won that lawsuit he would
have been worth five point two billion
dollars that's a lot of money he'd be a
billionaire look Trump lost of course
and afterward he openly admitted that he
knew he couldn't win saying I did it to
make his life miserable which I'm happy
about
which honestly makes sense doesn't it
because in Trump's heart he's just a
vindictive bad man he's the kind of guy
who thinks the movie Sophie's Choice is
about a woman who got to give up one of
her children but the Trump statement
there actually gets to the key
characteristic of slap suits the whole
point is to put the defendant through a
difficult painful experience and even if
cases fail in lower courts as they often
do the plaintiffs can find ways to
extend them through intensive discovery
requests depositions and appeals that
drain the target's time and resources
and alarmingly journalists are not the
only ones targeted with slap suits in
some cases they can be used to silence
citizen activists take the residents of
Uniontown Alabama after a waste disposal
company agreed to store toxic coal ash
in a landfill near their homes some
members of a local group posted about
their concerns on their Facebook page
but in 2016 the company behind the
landfill sued four members of the group
for 30 million dollars which is a
ridiculous amount to sue anyone for
let along people living in a community
where the median household income is
just $14,000 although to be fair the
attorney representing the landfill
claimed that that 30 million dollar
figure wasn't actually as bad as it
sounds
the 30 million dollars I think his bit
it actually was 15 there were two counts
but they each contain 15 oh that's okay
it's not 30 million dollars it's two
counts of 15 million dollars well you
could say it's five counts of six
million dollars or 30 counts of 1
million or 3 billion counts each
containing one cent the point is math is
fun now now thankfully after the ACLU
stepped in to help the residents defend
themselves the company voluntarily
withdrew the lawsuit but the experience
clearly left its mark on the community
it has scared a lot of people in his ear
for speaking up because those individual
are afraid to get their back legs not
knowing that that's just a scare tactic
to get you to leave things alone so they
can continue their power and control to
do what they want to do yeah she's
exactly right but the problem with scare
tactics is that they work because things
that could hurt you are scary the only
people who aren't scared of anything
look like this and look at that smiling
idiot able to feel joy because he
believes more than literally anything in
the world that his soul has been
liberated from 75 million-year-old alien
spirits that a psychiatrist helped
paralyze under the pretense of income
tax inspections seems nice Tommy Boy
seems real nice the thing is pretty much
everyone from judges to legal scholars
agrees that slap suits are a scourge
that is why 30 states have some form of
anti slap laws which vary significantly
but broadly can enable defendants to
force plaintiffs to justify their claim
early on and if they can't do that the
case is not only dismissed but in some
states the defendant is then awarded
attorneys fees now when they are well
crafted these laws can strike an
important balance between protecting
legitimate claims and deterring
time-wasting the problem is 20
states don't have those laws and with no
federal anti slap legislation plaintiffs
can simply file a suit in one of those
States one of which is West Virginia and
that is actually where Bob Murray sued
us despite the fact that neither he nor
I live there and we are far from the
only critics that he sued over the years
it's not the first time Murray has sued
a journalist for coverage he saw
unfavorably according to the Washington
Post he's filed at least nine lawsuits
against journalists and their news
organizations between 2001 and 2015 for
reports that they saw as critical and
since Murray likes to sue we're not
gonna say another word about now I I get
I get that he is clearly joking there
but that is also the exact culture of
fear that Murray may be trying to create
here lawsuits like his make people think
twice before reporting on his business
or pointing things out like the fact
that Bob Murray's general facial
expression answers the question what
would it look like if an egg was
mentally undressing you and I would
knock you eyes up here egg
and I would argue some of Murray suits
have clearly been attempts to bully
people into silence sometimes over
incredibly trivial slights he sued an
editorial cartoonist over this
unflattering cartoon of him which is
just pathetic who sues a cartoonist
you think I'm gonna go to court over
this thing that I found online which
appears to be me presenting a tiered
cake made with syringes condoms and
broken glass I can only assume that's a
metaphor for this show in which case
nailed it no notes blowing is also
through this couple James and Lisa CEO
Xie in 2012 they held a short protest
outside Murray Energy's Ohio
headquarters with only about 20 people
marching around it looked like this and
that has to be the least intimidating
protest I have ever seen one sign calls
him mr. Murray and another is in serif
font it is less a protest and more an
interoffice memo but but Murray
nevertheless sued not only the CEO
Shia's but also a local newspaper the
chagrin Valley Times for their coverage
of it now both the COCs and the
newspaper beats Murray's claims for
defamation bus he tied them both up in
appeals for years and the newspapers
defense cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars in fact the appellate court
judge even explicitly wrote in his
decision that Murray suit shows why Ohio
should adopt an anti slap statute
putting out of the paper had completely
removed all their coverage of Murray
from their site which the judge said was
an example of the chilling effects a
suit like this has and that is the point
here lawsuits are like famous Instagram
punks they don't have to work to be
considered very very successful and by
cultivating a reputation for being
aggressively litigious Murray may have
actually got what he wanted and
successfully applied a chokehold on how
he is covered and while it is hard to
show you an unreported story in
researching this piece we did actually
stumble on to ongoing lawsuits involving
Murray that have got almost no press
which is honestly strange because once
you hear the details I think you'll
agree that they
we should have now in one Murray
discloses that two women who had worked
for him had alleged harassment and the
perpetration of a hostile work
environment by mr. Murray and while he
denies those claims he also makes paying
those women considerable sums of money
in confidential settlements in a
separate ongoing lawsuit a different
former employee alleges there were
numerous attempts by Murray to kiss her
on the lips pulling it into him to quote
Copperfield and calling her into his
office on one occasion to give him hot
water with lemon while he was wearing
nothing but his underwear and what
possible thought process could have led
to that well let's see I'm horny I've
got some a little bit of a sore throat
I'd really like to solve both problems
in a way that makes a female employee
feel subhuman wait a minute I think I've
got it Bob you've done it again you
clever little coal Goblin but wait wait
because it gets worse the same complaint
also claims that Murray had the
plaintiff on more than one occasion get
on her hands and knees to locate or pick
up items for him including one time when
she was required to find a small hard
object he had dropped and he only told
her after she found it that it was a
kidney stone he fished out of the toilet
after pass again yeah yeah yeah I know
that that is absolutely nauseating to
remember you chose this you all chose to
be here everyone in this audience could
have gone to sea stop tonight instead
tickets are now available from $50
that's a great deal for a classic New
York show and sure it's not gonna blow
your mind it stomp but but it's been
around for nearly 30 years for good
reason and that reason is at no point
did they force their audience to imagine
this man fishing out his own kidney
stone from a toilet it's a good show
now that now I have to sell you Murray
denies all of those allegations which he
says are concocted and claims that the
woman is using the litigation as a
vehicle to harass and publicly embarrass
him in an attempt to strong-arm him into
a settlement although I will also tell
you that one of her colleagues backed
her up in a separate deposition saying
she told her the kidney stone story at
the time and had described Murray as
screaming at her to find it fight it and
what was possibly the rush there was
Murray honestly worried that someone
else was going to find his people first
I got it I got Bob's rock I'm gonna
be a millionaire it's genuinely hard to
find the right response to all of that
once you've heard it although I do think
a seven-foot squirrel quoting a
justifiably angry miner may have
actually said it best each it man
exactly beautifully put the point is
it's a little weird that these lawsuits
didn't get wider coverage these are
serious allegations of workplace
misconduct involving the chairman of the
country's largest private coal company a
highly public figure who constantly
practive at his closeness to the
president and his role in shaping energy
and environmental policy an old okie
that one reason might be the
organization's are justifiably wary of
getting sued by Murray because even if
they are baseless his lawsuits can do
major damage ours wound up costing over
$200,000 in legal fees and even though
our insurance covered part of it and we
were lucky that HBO stood by us this
lawsuit was infuriating took up a lot of
time and resources and resulted in a
tripling of our local insurance premiums
despite the fact that to reiterate we
won this case
here's the thing we badly need effective
anti slap loss nationwide to deter
powerful people like Bob Murray from
using the courts to shut down people's
legitimate dissent and I know that after
tonight Murray will probably sue us
again even though everything I've said
has been rigorously vetted by our
lawyers who may I add are getting very
tired with us because well we reached
out to Murray last week to review the
details that we plan to include in this
piece he wrote a letter back not address
directly to us but to our bosses at AT&T
and HBO saying we were falsely vilifying
him launching scurrilous attacks and
arguing that none of his lawsuits are
slap suits which they absolutely are so
I guess here we go again it is yet
another Bob Murray attempts to bully
people into silence and he's been doing
this for decades but you know what I
will stand behind our first piece and
I'll stand behind this one and as for
the jokes that we made about him we are
more than covered there the judge in our
case pointed out that the Supreme Court
has consistently protected loose
figurative language that cannot
reasonably be understood to convey facts
about someone basically jokes are fine
and I've got to say it would be really
tempting to say a bunch of loose
figurative things about Bob Murray right
now and not not just on our behalf but
on behalf of every small newspaper and
individual that he sued and on behalf of
every employee who's built in
ill-treated by his company and who may
have wanted to tell him to say eat
but couldn't and here is where I
actually have some bad news and some
good news for you the bad news is the
last two years have honestly just been
too exhausting so I'm afraid I am NOT
going to say anything more about Bob
Murray tonight the good news is why
would I when I can simply sing it
instead
he went to court against the world's
worst sport and learned important
lessons on the way we spoke with perfect
camp and got accused of slander because
Bob Murray wants to make us pay so even
though he'll threaten legal Armageddon
we have just one tiny thing to say Bob
Murray can go himself today
[Applause]
don't be better respond to Bob Mary's
complete please welcome to the
show the suck my balls pop dancers
[Applause]
watch he went to the Louvre and spinet
Mona Lisa's meet Phil the rocket with
Barbies and you shot it into space keep
lunch and nancy kerrigan and watch the
cry4ba commanded us to find a man that
started one that's right if we discuss
Bob Murray in a way no reasonable person
could construe this factual we can say
whatever the we like so come on
everyone let's head to the streets
[Applause]
Wow he'll stroll into a stranger's home
in there weezing protected speech to
tell Bob Marie to eat Bob Marie is
that the guy who dipped his goals in my
hot dog water that's exactly who I'm
talking about can I bring my car it's
not ideal it'll be fine if I leave it
here right
[Music]
Cosby's drug supplier Jeffrey app stop
stop stop stop John as HBO's legal
counsel please stop I have something
very important to say Bob Murray walked
through the door he wasn't wearing pants
that day has taken falls on full display
cram that mop his anal balls broke his
butt cheeks far and wide he told the
tourists to look inside grab some sweets
these are all real things Bob Murray did
see in court about Bob Murray I
believe you've heard of him you mean the
Zodiac killer say about here
[Music]
man Fox
[Applause]
[Music]
you